wann ist mein bruder gestorben
ich glaube dass realismus im kino nach
wie vor eine kunst ist eine kunst des
spiels eine kunst derzeit eine kunst der
geduld und eben deshalb ist es für mich
so eine wohltat den film mensch es dabei
ist sie von keine pflanze meine kinder
schlafen oben
es tut mir so leid könntest du jetzt
bitte diesen schwachsinn hier beenden
das kann ich im film der in einen
kleinen küstenstädtchen in massachusetts
an der atlantikküste spielt erzählt die
geschichte eines mannes der nach jahren
der selbst quälerei der isolation zurück
kehrt in seine heimatstadt um sich
seinem eigenen schicksal zu stellen der
familientragödie die ihr selber
verschuldet hat und die ihn aus seinem
leben heraus katapultiert hat jetzt soll
er sich um seinen neffen kümmern den
sohn seines toten bruders ist verstehe
ich nicht welchen teil genau verstehen
sie denn nicht ich kann ich seine form
und sein
das ist nicht möglich
ja ich bin natürlich davon ausgegangen
dass es mit ihm gesprochen
nein wird gerade dieser mann durch den
tod seines bruders dazu gezwungen sich
seiner geschichte neu zu stellen und wie
er auf diese weise zurück findet in sein
leben wie er vielleicht kein glück aber
doch eine neue chance findet zu leben
davon erzählt dieser film 1,14 2857 zwei
bier pro stunde
großartig dann habt ihr so gut wie gar
nichts getroffen ja ich habe dir doch
gesagt sich drehte kürze nein das kannst
du da jetzt wirklich nicht ernst meinen
oder
mal duschen erzählt mit großer geduld
davon und vor allen dingen mit zwei ganz
großartigen schauspielern mit casey
affleck in der hauptrolle und mit
michelle williams als seine ex ehefrau
mit der er sich wirklich herzzerreißende
szene wieder versöhnt ohne dass
gleichzeitig alles bewältigt wäre ich
nehme an du weißt nichts davon wenn du
möchtest kannst du ihn sehen hinten
jemals zusammen essen gehen
meinst du dich es ist ein film der viele
fragen offen lässt so wie das leben
selbst fragen offen lässt und den ich
deshalb nur wärmstens empfehlen kann
mensch ist dabei dass sie ein großes
stück wirklichkeit kino wie es nur alle
paar jahre vorkommt weißt du ja kann
jederzeit bei uns grund wenn er am
wochenende her kommen willst du sein
vormund werden
[Musik]